[Music]
good morning John it's Wednesday May 9th
we're going to start with the good news
and we're going to move to the bad news
the good news is that I have officially
accepted your challenge friend of mine
who you may all recognize as the other
guy from will you miss me when I'm gone
from your pants I suggested that it
would indeed be a good thing for me to
write a song every two weeks it's not
Jonathan Coulton but it's as good as I
can do every time it's my Wednesday I
sing a song the song I'm about to
perform is something I've written for a
guy who worked really hard and got to
see some of the results from his work
but not all of them because he has now
passed his legacy on
[Music]
the day that you died was a good day
hundreds of people wished you on your
way
Neil Gaiman wrote about you on his blog
and you and you girl ate mini corndogs
Oh goodbye
26 year old me you made a lot of money
got a master's degree and you married a
girl we adore but now I reap the rewards
for all the hard work Hank your bank
account swelled a lot before it shrank
but you could have work maybe a little
bit harder yeah I could have used a few
$1,000 so goodbye 26 year-old me you
made a lot of money got a master's
degree
meet a girl we adore but now I reap the
rewards you watched a lot of people get
married John and Sarah John and hey
Ethan and Sarah Jason and Ashley holy
crap
I bet they'll all have babies oh good
bye 26 year old me
you made a lot of money got a master's
degree
meet a girl a door but now
rewards but now I read the reward
yeah
the reward
day
but Yugo was a good I hope you all
enjoyed that because now I have bad news
today we introduced a new feature to
Brotherhood 2.0 we're adding this
feature under less than ideal
circumstances Brotherhood 2.0 viewer
Travis bond has created the foundation
to decrease worldsuck s-- worldsuck
index which you can also find on the
left hand sidebar and unfortunately the
worldsuck index is debuting at suck
little red this is because Brotherhood
2.0 viewer Danny Chow has just lost his
best friend Danny's friend Randy
recently beat cancer but has now died of
pneumonia and I think that it's safe to
say that this has increased suck levels
pretty dramatically for Danny and for
Randy's family so for the next two weeks
all donations to the foundation to
decrease worldsuck will be donated to
Randy's family John I'll see you
tomorrow